- No recipe.
This is great 'cause I've definitely done
this many times before.
(dramatic music)
- I don't bake anything at all.
(upbeat 60's English music)
- Actually, I don't cook at all
so if my dad watches this,
he's gonna be super proud of me.
- Okay, I'm gonna kill this.
- I'll be using two eggs.
'Cause it always takes two to tango.
- Wait, your not telling me anything?
- I know you need flour.
- Are you kidding?
Wait, you're serious?
- These eggs are warm by the way.
It's probably fine.
- Put the spatula in the bowl,
you know what I'm say'in.
- I really like cookie dough,
so, I usually just eat
all the cookie dough,
instead of actually making them.
- Yeah, this is how you bake.
You just throw shit in a bowl,
and hope that it turns out okay.
- These cookies are about
to be vanilla-y as [bleep].
- Baking soda is a powder that you put
into things that you are going to bake.
- Definitely failing right now.
- Brown sugar, and I have white sugar,
and I am quite the fan of
interracial relationships so,
I'm just gonna throw both in here.
- I'm trying to get it
to look like cookie dough consistency.
(laughing)
- I don't have a knife, so I'm just gonna
cut it with my hands.
- I'm gonna do one cup.
Okay, little too much.
- This is not that bad.
- I did such a good job.
- I feel like I'm a caveman creating fire
for the first time.
- Oh, snap.
- You wanna lick the spoon?
- A lot of people like think
that they're good at baking,
but they're really not.
- This is why I don't bake.
- Wow, its getting hot in here.
- Ah, ah, um dang.
- Nah, nah.
- No, it's not really cooked.
- Oh my god, these are so good.
- Its not bad; its not, its
definitely not a cookie.
- I probably should learn how to cook.
- Yeah, I learned respect grandmas,
never take the instructions
on packaging for granted.
- If I was on a deserted kitchen set
in the middle of a studio,
and had all of these ingredients,
in front of me.
I could make some pretty bomb cookies.